I think the writer who most influenced
me was hired Murray Rothbard I'm rain
probably George Orwell in 1984 and an
animal farm like both of which I read as
a child you know I'd actually have to
say maybe PJ O'Rourke I'd like Benjamin
Franklin hunter s thompson through his
books Hells Angels specifically and also
fear and loading the campaign trail
probably Milton Friedman and that was a
college thing as a reaction to all of
the stuff I got of economics courses in
every other course it was Julian Simon
really who's kind of my mentor he
started out you know looking kind of her
government solutions that they
discovered that really the human
ingenuity and human freedom is what is
what makes everything better th Lawrence
because he espoused to certain kind of
free weeding human emotional Liberty my
former boss actually John Stossel
Virginia postural who weird late was the
editor of Reason magazine I don't
remember how I discovered Reason
magazine and but it was like God
my hope is the Republican Party will
finally start to see the light on the
immigration issue it's either at this
point wake up or perish I think you have
to look to our immigrants to remind us
of what America is about the greatest
hope for freedom is that socialism and
it's American variant interest group
liberalism doesn't work I best hope of
freedom is just to make government in
irrelevant by technological progress we
may not have free markets but we've got
for your minds never before in this
country even though we have a more
fragmented media it means that the sort
of traditional centers don't have the
same power as they had before the truth
that manifests itself through social
media and original reporting that gets
manifested through Facebook and Twitter
well organizations like reason and enemy
sis and Kato which educate people in a
way substantially differently than they
were taught in the government schools
students for liberty groups these
college kids miss them I mean I'm
depressed most of the time i'm a
pessimist but these students are excited
they get it they're smart and a new
burst of enthusiasm they are introducing
the concept of gay marriage in france
and this is a great for gay marriage in
pot